[Dr. Emily Zarka]
Imagine a calling to
you from the darkness,
the voice of someone you
loved who recently died.
You're terrified,
but you can't ignore
the hypnotic promise
of seeing them again.
You venture outside to find
the source, a fatal mistake.
This is the lure of the Nishi.
Hailing from Bengali
folk tradition,
these cruel monsters are
also known as Nishi Daak,
which roughly translates
to call of the darkness
or the call of the night.
The lines between
demon spirit and deity
are often blurred in cultures
of the Indian subcontinent.
The clear
good-versus-evil dualism
seen more commonly in
the western hemisphere
doesn't exist in the same way.
The Nishi falls firmly
into the malevolent end
of ghostly beings
and teaches us a lot about
the culture it comes from.
[rousing music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
The Nishi Daak is one of
many bhoots, or ghosts,
in Bengali tradition.
There are so many types of
ghost stories in Bengal.
By Bengal, I mean the
country of Bangladesh
as well as West Bengal
in India, the state.
We used to all be
one big region.
Of course, after the
partition of India in 1947
when we achieved
our independence,
we became two
separate countries.
But our stories and our
folklore traverse those borders
of both nationality,
religion, class, and the like.
That's Dr. Sayantani DasGupta,
assistant professor
at Columbia University
and children's and YA author.
[DasGupta] But the Nishi
is a slightly different
malevolent entity
than the rest of
Bengali ghost lore.
Tales of these
harmful night spirits
are prevalent in small
and rural villages.
They pose a deadly threat to
those who wander at night.
Nishi call out to peaceful
sleepers in a familiar voice,
usually a deceased loved one.
One story I've heard
about the Nishi
is that they are a
kind of disembodied,
ghostly form that can call you,
mimicking the voice
of a loved one.
So, for instance, if at night,
walking by a deserted
bamboo forest,
you were to hear somebody
calling your name,
somebody very familiar,
for instance, an aunt
or a beloved cousin
calling you maybe even in a
nickname that only they know,
don't turn around
because it may be a Nishi
trying to trick you
out of your spirit.
While the monster
adopts the voice
of someone their victim knows,
these malevolent spirits
aren't necessarily the ghost
of the person's voice
they are adopting.
The complex nature of Nishi
is reflective of the
spiritual community
from which these
monsters originate.
The very idea of a ghost
becomes additionally complex
in cultures where
spiritual practices
center around the
ideas of reincarnation,
ancestral worship, and
karma, like Hinduism.
In Hinduism, the subtle
body or second body
is the part of a person
that is reincarnated into
another physical form.
The deceased corporeal form
must be completely obliterated
so the subtle body can move on,
hence the preference
for cremation.
This also means Bengali ghosts
don't have gravesites to haunt.
Bengalis, and particularly
Hindu Bengalis,
have the notion of
rebirth and reincarnation,
and so Bengali ghosts are
sometimes perceived of
as recently deceased people
who have not been able to enter
the cycle of reincarnation.
But sometimes Bengali ghosts
are actually thought
of as creatures,
monsters of their own kind,
a kind of different species
in and of themselves.
Now, Nishi or Nishi Daak
are not exactly among
this category of spirit
because they exist in
a far more sinister
and disembodied form,
unlike a lot of
other Bengali ghosts.
An exclusively malevolent
spirit like a Nishi
can be the result of incomplete
or improper funerary rites.
The deceased fails to
transition their subtle body
and thus cannot be reincarnated.
And since no one
wants more Nishi,
protecting and executing
cultural burial rights
is paramount.
If we see the call of a Nishi
as a way the spiritual body
continues to link itself
to the physical body,
the corporeality of the voice
becomes particularly
interesting.
What if a Nishi cannot be heard?
Does it cease to exist?
Or does it become even
more ambiguous and ominous?
The fact that the Nishi
can steal or mimic the voice
of a deceased loved one
seems particularly
threatening in this sense.
It suggests we cannot fully
trust the dead or our own ears
in such a way that it
will cause our demise,
which, quite frankly,
is pretty terrifying.
Yet the call of the
Nishi is hard to ignore.
Only the chosen victim can hear
the Nishi's hypnotic voice.
Interestingly, these beings
cannot call out to you
more than two times,
so superstition dictates
that you never respond to anyone
calling your name at night
unless you hear it three times.
Those who do fall under
the influence of a Nishi
fall into a trance
and will follow the distant
voices to a remote area.
And these nighttime
strolls are dangerous.
If one is unable to break
the Nishi's influence,
they disappear,
presumably killed.
While the Nishi can call to
or even grab their victims,
visual details of the
monster tend to be vague.
In some accounts,
the Nishi appears as a
shadowy or indistinct form
resembling the person's
voice they mimic.
In others, they are an
all-white, misty entity
with a vaguely human shape.
The ambiguity highlights
its mutability
and lets the
imagination run wild.
In one story translated
by Dr. Suchitra Samanta,
a Nishi directs its
attention to a little boy.
The boy shared a close bond
with his aunt who
helped raise him.
He would lovingly catch
his aunt's favorite
freshwater fish to eat.
When she died suddenly,
the boy was too
devastated by grief
to perform his
aunt's last rites.
He would not eat or speak,
becoming ill himself.
Exorcists were brought in,
amulets and charms applied,
but nothing worked.
One night, the
boy woke suddenly,
claiming he heard his
aunt's voice calling to him.
Soon rumors spread of a figure
sitting in a tree
at a nearby pond.
Then after a heavy monsoon rain,
a midnight fog
encased the village.
The boy again hears his
aunt calling to him,
begging him to come
catch her fish.
So he sneaks out of the house
and begins to collect the fish,
but then he spots a
figure in the trees.
Fear brings the boy
back to his senses,
and with much effort
he is able to run.
But he doesn't get
far before a long arm
snatches his basket of fish,
and the boy falls
into a dead faint.
Three days pass before
he regains consciousness.
Everyone warns his mother to
keep a close eye on the boy,
for next time, he might have
his neck broken by the Nishi.
But the monster is relentless
and lures the boy into the pond.
He walks straight in,
sinking below the surface.
His body is dragged up
in the fisherman's nets
the next morning.
Elements in this
story give insight
into some cultural
practices and taboos.
It isn't farfetched that
the boy's affliction
was treated with a variety of
methods, including exorcism.
Belief in spirit possession
and malicious sorcery
is common in this region even
today, although controversial.
Some religious sites
are known for exorcisms
but face increased
scrutiny in the modern day.
An afflicted person
might make a pilgrimage
to one of these
temples or shrines
to remove any negative spiritual
or supernatural ailment.
Policy reforms and
growing awareness
of mental health challenges
have made these temples
and shrines divisive,
arguing that they
encourage superstition
and can do more harm.
But others counter
that they offer a form
of traditional
alternative healing
that should not be
dismissed or demonized.
Like many other
night spirit stories,
the victim wanders
off and dies at night.
Because of this,
Nishi influence is often
said to be responsible
for a particular trance-like
state, sleepwalking.
Fun fact, I used to
sleepwalk as a kid.
One night, my parents found
me knee deep in our pool,
something I have zero memory of.
Death by sleepwalking is rare,
but injuries aren't uncommon.
Perhaps the Nishi
serves as an explanation
for this strange phenomenon
and helps the
community stay alert
and keep sleepwalkers safe.
Nishi Daak stories are also told
to make sense of
horrible illnesses.
So let's say there's a child
who, for no explainable reason,
without any treatment,
is getting sicker, kind of
wasting away in a family.
You might say that the Nishi
has called away
their life force.
So the notion is that maybe
somewhere else in the village
or somewhere in the locality,
a wealthy family with an
ill child of their own
has employed a tantric or
a magician of some sort
to wander around
the neighborhood
saying a particular
magical mantra
and carrying around a
hollowed-out green coconut
in which they hope to trap
the essence, the soul,
or the life force of
a healthy young person
and give it to this ill one.
So in a community with high
rates of infant mortality
and childhood illness,
stories like those
of the Nishi Daak
may have been a way for
families to make sense
of what was completely
un-understandable
and happening before their eyes.
[Zarka] Let's go back to the
creepiest part of this monster
and the thing that
literally defines it,
the disembodied
voice in the night.
People have been trying to
understand the phenomena
of the disembodied voice
for quite some time.
From exploring the validity
of religious communications
to assessing clairvoyance,
even now, we look for answers
in both the secular
and the scientific.
As technology and urbanization
continue to evolve
and literally bring
light to the darkness,
so do the stories of the Nishi,
but that doesn't make
them any less important.
As a Bengali immigrant
daughter to the US,
Bengali folk stories,
stories about flying horses,
princes and princesses,
evil serpent kings,
and even monsters like the
carnivorous, drooling rakkhosh
and of course the
ever-present Bengali bhoot
were literally what connected
me to my cultural roots.
These were stories
that were told to me
by not only my parents
but my grandparents.
Oral stories are critical
to communities
throughout the world.
And I think particularly
to diasporic communities
who are raising children
far from their homeland,
folk stories, monster
stories, ghost stories
are a way to connect young
people to their origins,
to their ancestors,
and to their sources
of cultural belief.
These stories are deliciously
frightening sometimes
to listen to,
but they're also
deeply meaningful.
Somewhat ironically,
given the Nishi
Daak's dangerous call,
in speaking and
hearing their stories,
we preserve their importance.
The deceased corporeal...
Community stay alert and
keep safewalkers safe.
Oh my God, I started it
and couldn't stop myself.
Nishi Daaks, Daaks.